President Trump may be looking to roll
back another of his predecessors legacy
regulations this one involves fuel
efficiency rules for vehicles that could
end up costing you a lot of money
here's correspondent Doug mackelway EPA
Administrator Scott Pruitt a lightning
rod for criticism from the left may see
a new level of vitriol come April 1st
that's when EPA plans to roll out a
rollback of the Obama administration's
fuel economy standards the president put
me in charge at the EPA to get reform to
get changes made to make sure that we
trust people across this country as
opposed to treat them like adversaries
in 2012 the Obama administration imposed
new standards which would have required
automakers to nearly double the average
fuel economy of new cars and light
trucks by the year 2025 to fifty four
point five miles per gallon vastly
reducing fossil fuel consumption and
greenhouse gas emissions proponents say
but at great expense to the automobile
industry it adds to car prices it
restricts car choices but really the
worst thing it does is it makes cars
less safe you increase the miles per
gallon it gets but you also decrease its
crash worthiness adding to automakers
dilemma is a potential balkanization of
fuel economy standards that would
further increase costs California has
its own tougher fuel standards which
thirteen states and DC follow its
Attorney General Xavier Becerra vowed
today to maintain those standards
regardless of what EPA does tweeting
California is prepared to take any steps
necessary to protect our planet and
people but Sara's threat comes as an
internal EPA document on how officials
should talk to the public about global
warming is also coming under fire The
Associated Press contacted 15 climate
scientists who said the talking points
don't reflect reality
the EPA won't comment on how much fuel
economy standards will change noting the
final determination will be signed this
Sunday with a Tuesday ceremony at a
suburban Virginia car dealership
Shannon Stubb mackelway thank you